E aí
[Música]
a fazer uma pergunta Quem é e já sonhou
em trabalhar puxando uma carroça e
catando no lixo dos outros quem sonha
isso para os seus filhos ganhando menos
de um salário mínimo por mês hoje no
Brasil sou mais de um milhão de pessoas
que trabalham dessa forma mas nenhuma
delas sonhou então nessa situação sem
equipamentos de proteção sem direitos
trabalhistas acordam sem saber se vão
conseguir comer naquele dia sem
dignidade eu trabalhei durante 10 anos
em multinacionais E outros dez anos em
projetos de destinação de resíduos
sólidos como os aterros sanitários há
três anos criam Startup voltada para a
logística reversa com o objetivo de
inverter a realidade trazendo dignidade
para quem trabalha na cadeia da
reciclagem durante as minhas visitas em
aterros sanitários alguns cheirava muito
bem o lixo muito lixo um cheiro
insuportável mas o quê
e me fazia embrulhar o estômago era ver
pessoas ali catando lixo para vender e
comprar comida mas algumas coisas estão
errados ali na verdade tu não tava
errado porque que nós aceitar vamos
aquilo Porque tudo bem ter carroceiros e
reconhecer eles ainda como agentes
ambientais só que manter na dessa
maneira informal com minha formação era
voltado para área financeira eu fui
entender os atores dessa cadeia os
interesses e financeiros e os fluxos
econômicos da reciclagem e algumas
coisas começaram a ficar mais claras o
mercado da reciclagem tem um potencial
gigante de mais de um trilhão de reais
por ano só no Brasil o potencial
estimado em mãos e bilhões de reais e
aqui cerca de trinta por cento de tudo
que é gerado é possível ser reciclável
só que a gente só nesse com a dois por
cento disso
Oi e para que o material chegue até a
indústria da reciclagem é preciso
realizar a logística reversa que na
maior parte das vezes tem o catador lá
no início do processo só que o problema
é que o caçador fica com uma parcela
muito pequena do valor de venda deste
produto reciclável sempre é de 25 a 30
por cento e com muito esforço tira uma
média de 450 A 600 reais por mês
dependendo ainda da sua produtividade ou
seja se ele ficar doente se tiver algum
acidente ele fica sem ganhar nada e
acredite são mais de 1 milhão de
catadores e só 10 por cento deles estão
organizados em cooperativas de triagem e
recebem ainda o material todo misturado
e precisam separar aquele realmente
tenha valor de venda
e hoje são quase duas mil associações de
catadores do Brasil só que a maior parte
delas não tem os documentos exigidos
para o poder operar dentro da Lei
consequentemente Eles não conseguem se
relacionar diretamente com as indústrias
e aí precisam ter atravessadores
intermediários para comprar sua produção
porque a insegurança jurídica
trabalhista digestão e impede se com
esse crescimento das cooperativas e o
resumo de tudo é que o caçador Continua
trabalhando de maneira informal por
causa de 5 segundos
já são 5 segundos que nós precisamos
para separar o material quando a gente
joga no lixo para que a gente não joga
ele misturado imagine em países europeus
Eu geralmente digo que eles desistiram
do ser humano lá construíram grandes
máquinas caras que usam muita energia
elétrica para separar o material que
devia ter sido separado em casa por isso
que defendemos que o incentivo que as
pessoas estejam incentivar as na verdade
a começar a separar vidro com vidro Pet
compete papelão papelão em suas casas
porque assim a gente consegue mudar a
vida de mais de um milhão de pessoas
podemos mudar na vida do mundo e foi
depois estudar bastante entendesse
assuntos econômicos da cadeia da
reciclagem que eu resolvi procurar um
novo modelo um novo ecossistema que
incentivar empresas e pessoas a
separarem o material na fonte quando o
material separado ele não precisa ser
e até uma estação de triagem ele já tá
puro menos contaminado e foi lá em 2018
que a gente refeces recheados rearranjos
dos Fundos econômicos com ajuda de uma
grande multinacional reduzindo a
eficiência da cadeia logística e
contratamos pessoas como são Luís umas
carroceiro que foi possível contratar
CLT da os equipamentos segurança e hoje
ele é inclusive bancarizado chegou até
dormir Albergue mas agora consegue
construir a sua própria casa e nessa
solução tem outros incentivados os bares
restaurantes conseguem fazer a separação
e aí economizam com a coleta porque
agora eles não pagam mais por ela os
consumidores que participam agora de uma
plataforma incentivo recebem Recompensas
pela separação sem sair de casa essa
plataforma de incentivo já é realidade
em alguns bairros em São Paulo só que
pretende que cada vez mais pessoas
possam se engajar com a separação
correta de embalagens vazias
o qual é retirado lá no seus condomínios
em suas casas a consequência disso é que
temos mais pessoas mais microempresários
inclusive coletando os materiais e menos
pessoas da triagem porque os produtos já
chegaram separados aumentando a
quantidade de resíduo reciclável com
eficiência e cumprindo as leis
trabalhistas esse modelo inclusive já
está em análise para ser levado para os
Estados Unidos e pra Europa porque
realmente estamos transformando a
reciclagem em um negócio interessante
onde é possível dar emprego segurança
trabalhista proteção e ser
economicamente viável trazendo dignidade
Os catadores pessoal está nas nossas
mãos a escolha do Futuro que Queremos
para o nosso país e se a gente parar de
ser de jogar automaticamente material e
usar esse 5 segundos a gente muda a vida
de milhões de pessoas